These cheap paper rockets from a different
project will cruse over 300 feet, if you've
got the right equipment to get them airborne.
In this project you'll learn how to convert
common sprinkler parts into a powerful and
portable hand-held rocket launcher.
For this project, I based my design on the
style of an AK-47 assault rifle. I rounded
up these PVC sprinkler parts for about $45
at a local hardware store. To get started,
we'll need to measure some 9" lengths of 2"
PVC pipe, and when those are cut, they connect
to these reducing adaptors. Together, these
will act as the pressure chambers that
power the rocket launch. I'm placing the parts
on my worktable in the basic form of the finished
rifle, so I can measure custom lengths of
1" pipe for the body. I'm happy with the look,
so let's cut a 2' length of 1/2" pipe for
the barrel, and commit to this design by making
it permanent. Purple primer will go on first
to clean the connections, and when they're
dry, it's time to add the PVC cement. When
we make our connections, it's important to
use glue on both components, and twist them
together to make sure we get a great seal.
There's gonna be a lot of pressure in these
chambers, and we don't wanna take any chances
with a bad connection. Alright, the frame
is complete, and now we can focus on adding
a pneumatic coupler to this cap. This will
allow us to pressurize our system with an
air compressor. The pneumatic coupling is
added by drilling a hole in the top of cap
and tapping the hole to form threads that
will secure the adaptor air tight. Next, we
can drill a hole in the other cap just big
enough for a momentary switch.
I'll shape the bottom with my belt sander and a rotary
tool so that this trigger cap will fit snug
on the handle. I'm getting this ready for
painting, so I'll need to clean off the stickers
with some adhesive remover, and tape over
the parts that I don't want exposed. We still
need to attach the trigger before we can paint,
and we also need to attach some doorbell wire
as well as this poly tubing. These together
will join the electrical system to the trigger
switch in the cap. To connect them up, we'll
have to cut a hole just bigger than the tube,
and we're at it, let's drill a hole in the
center of this plug as well because we're
gonna need that later. Next let's strip
our doorbell wire so we can connect each wire
to the switch. When those are in place, and
tightened, we can secure the switch on the
cap, then pull the wires through the bottom
hole. We need to get these wires through the
protective tubing and I found that could be
done by sucking a string through the tube
first, then attaching the wires to the string.
This way, they pull through the tube easily.
Alright, the tube is in place, and we can
add some hot glue to help keep it there, and
now we're ready to attach the trigger to the
frame. Hot glue goes on the back, and it presses
into place nicely. I'll add just a little
more glue to fill in the gaps. Ok, it's time
for a paint job, and I think it will be fun
to use a variety of camouflage paints, so
I'll hang this up and start attacking it with
4 different colors. I'm letting each layer
dry before adding the next color, and just
spraying in random patterns for effect. I'll
add a coat of finish, and when it's dry I
think it looks pretty good. The masking tape
we used to cover the trigger switch and pneumatic
coupling can all be removed, and then thread
tape can be added to each of the threaded
connector nipples. We need to make sure these
are screwed back on fairly tightly because
we don't want any air to leak. Let's add the
in-line sprinkler valve next and then screw
the barrel onto that. The valve wires get
pulled through the 90 degree joint, and the
elbow presses nicely onto the solenoid casing.
Now it's time to rig up the electrical system.
The ends of each wire need to be sniped to
size and stripped to expose the bare copper
wire. The other side is made ready by pushing
the poly tube through the hole in the end
plug that we made earlier. Next, we need to
wire a 9 volt snap connector in series with
the valve and the switch, and that can be
done by twisting the ends together. I used
electrical tape to cover the connections and
it ends up looking like this. Now we can snap
our battery in place, and add hot glue to
hold the tubing inside the plug. When that's
cooled, the wires and battery tuck very comfortably
up into the casing to shield the battery from
the elements. The system is finished! At this
point you should have your very own "AK-47
style" compressed air rocket launcher. I'm
really happy with the way it looks and handles.
I've even made barrel adaptors for shooting
paintballs and water balloons, and a valve
stem adaptor for hooking up a bike pump for
anyone who doesn't have an air compressor.
A little pose for the camera, and I'm ready
to test out one of my 5 cent high pressure
paper rockets. Look for the video on how to
build those. Alright, all my neighbors are
at work, and the streets are clear so it's
time to fire. Woah, where did it go? I actually
lost sight of it, but after a few minutes
of searching, my little boy helped me find
it way down the street almost 300 feet away.
That's nearly the length of a football field!
And it's still in perfect condition, so let's
shoot it again! I'm firing these at 135PSI,
and they're out of sight every time. Well
this has far surpassed my expectations. Not
only can it launch rockets completely out
of sight, but it's portable, customizable,
and can be modified to launch paintballs and
water balloons hundreds of feet! That's it
for now. If you liked this project, perhaps
you'll like some of my others. Check them
out at www.thekingofrandom.com